and welcome to everybody uh we're going
to be starting in about three minutes I
just wanted to give you a chance to get
settled in
someone in the Q a I said hi so hi
and um
we are waiting for
Dr asadani to come who will be helping
present the webinar today
well he should be joining shortly
all right it's time so let's get started
doctor isadani should be joining us in
the meantime
I'll introduce the program and again as
I said my name is Stuart Creek I'm with
simply learn
and we're the delivery and
administrative partner for Caltech
Center for technology and management
education
which offers a program in cloud
computing
talking a little bit about that during
the session
we'll ask a few questions along the way
about you and the audience
and we will discuss cloud computing
careers
and then how Caltech can help you
break into that field
we'll look at some learner outcomes that
people have achieved and
we'll talk about how you can enroll in
the program
and then we'll take some of your
questions
so Dr Austin should be joining us and he
is an assistant professor
uh entry
College of engineering and management
nagpur
and
recently got his PhD so very proud of
that
um he's a specialist in cloud computing
for Azure AWS and other platforms
he's been named a Google Scholar so he's
very qualified
a lot of prestigious credentials with
him and I will be sharing with you later
is LinkedIn
uh link so that you can connect with him
I'll put that in the chat a bit later
well let's get started talking about
careers in cloud computing I see that Dr
assadani is here
yeah hi through it hi you want to tell
the folks a little bit more about
yourself doctor
sorry can you come again yes if you'd
like to uh please tell uh the audience a
little bit more about yourself okay okay
yeah yeah yeah sure sure thank you thank
you yes so uh good evening everyone
um yeah so
um my name is
and uh I have um I've done my PhD in
computer science and engineering
basically in cloud computing from vit
Vellore and um I am uh like I'm working
as a corporate trainer and associated
with SRI ramdeva College of engineering
and management working there as an
assistant professor and um yeah and I am
Microsoft certified trainer AWS
certified trainer uh three times uh
certified on AWS and Microsoft
and um yes I have been involved into
multiple corporate trainings and uh in
and outside of India and associated with
the Caltech University uh through simply
learn for delivering the postgraduate
program in cloud computing and
associated with iit's many iits through
uh intellipad at eurekas and simply
learn so so many platforms yeah so into
cloud and um basically fascinated and
passionate about training and teaching
people yeah so that is in short about me
yeah thank you Stuart for giving me the
opportunity thank you thank you
I appreciate that so we're going to be
talking about careers in cloud computing
and
you and I will both be commenting on
this but
cloud computing from the from the
commercial side
in terms of the size of the field and
its importance has
it's not only transformed Our Lives
by enabling things like
mobile computing
software as a service all of the types
of things that make available to you on
your desktop
services and capabilities that used to
require
uh Mainframe Computing or time sharing
um now you have the ability not only to
communicate to store information almost
infinitely
but also to create new Computing
environments any type of thing that you
might imagine
with
Computing servers and virtual servers on
Demand with storage on demand so the the
cloud has transformed our lives and our
lives in turn have transformed the
demand for cloud computing
um most recently with the
uh pandemic when we were told
to um
all work from home suddenly the ability
for us to interact
via the cloud became that much more
important to everyone
um
when we were told we had to interact
with
stores and businesses in a non-contact
fashion and had to use our mobile
devices or computers to do that
uh that also boosted the importance of
of the cloud so uh the the
technology is all pervasive in our lives
and the demand for people who can
manage and administer the technology
is constantly growing
um so you see some of these market
number software as a service and
platform as a service Market
um growing very rapidly and these were
pre-pandemic numbers
um the numbers have gone even higher so
um that's the commercial side of it
um from the from the point of view
from your point of view
um how is the technology changed and
grown
um in the last
five years even
um yeah so uh the technology has changed
a lot in the last few years and let me
tell you
um I mean um in fact uh like by 2025
almost 90 percent of the companies will
move towards Cloud okay
um so uh yeah the technology everything
now you will see uh even the startups
and uh even the established companies
are into cloud or uh they are they are
already into cloud or they are moving
into cloud and
um
yeah so to be in the cloud uh they are
moving into public Cloud platforms and
uh the the major Pro uh Market leaders
in the public Cloud platforms are uh
Amazon web services that is AWS
Microsoft Azure Google Cloud platform so
uh they are preferring from uh any of
these Cloud platforms only to move uh
into the market anyways later on I will
also uh show you um some numbers like uh
the career opportunities into the cloud
as well screw it yeah thank you
and when you talk about career
opportunities that's a great lead-in um
because
when you have a basis of cloud computing
skills when you're competent
as a cloud computing professional you
have a number of different potential
career paths so you can be a cloud
developer or Cloud engineer toward the
entry level
and then move up and across into
different specializations
you can move up into the cloud architect
position where you
um
design and
configure
complete Cloud architectures for an
Enterprise
you can become a cloud database
administrator if your interest and
passion is more along managing data
if you're interested in
cyber security
particular area of cloud security is
very important because
different
qualitatively from how you would protect
uh desktop system or a closed system for
an Enterprise and
the cloud devops engineer
position is also a
new and exciting position because
a nature of software development has
changed so drastically from
times when you would receive a software
release on a fixed schedule
every couple of months you get a notice
to install a new release of software on
a system
um and it would be numbered
2.5.18 or that type of thing
uh today with devops and with software
as a service
you find that
these types of uh updates are being done
seamlessly and without your
direct involvement or input they just
happen to happen because the
people manage administering the software
developing the software have the devops
cycle in place for continuous
integration continuous deployment and
the use of
that cycle on the cloud is again A
specialized kind of art form
where it's necessary to understand how
all the pieces interact and the cloud
devops engineer
ties that all together uh some other
aspects to careers and you had mentioned
some numbers that you wanted to share
yeah just give me a moment I'm just
showing yes uh can I just share my
screen through it yeah let me
once
you can mess that up you should be able
to do that uh yeah one second I I'm just
trying to do that
yes
um I can I think yeah I think uh my
screen is visible yes it is yeah thank
you
thank you yeah so guys
um hello everyone yeah so see uh the
different roles as said by Stuart
already so um you can be a cloud
administrator uh so that's one of the
rules and uh let me tell you uh to be a
cloud administrator you have to be good
on the admin side and the course in AWS
basically if I say uh to become a cloud
administrator is AWS isops admin
associate in Azure you have Microsoft
Azure administrator associate that is
ez104 and you can see guys the salary
range uh for a cloud admin associate
um arranges from this uh thing right so
dollar six five five three nine two
dollars eight one four five five and the
average salary is dollar seven two eight
zero nine correct then you have the
cloud support engineer
okay so um in in in in Cloud support
engineer
um
again the salary range uh average salary
is around dollar 90 uh thousand eight
one two dollars right so that's that's
pretty good then
um you would uh see the third role is
cloud security specialist uh okay so
they have the responsibility to ensure
the integrity and security of a
company's uh Cloud presence and
um uh here the average salary ranges
from uh ninety one thousand nine fifty
nine dollars okay then um you also have
a another rule that is of cloud network
engineer
wherein
um uh they they would handle the network
of the company so you have to be good in
the networking aspect so basically uh
you can go with uh AWS networking
specialty or Azure networking specialty
for uh becoming good in this particular
domain and the average salary ranges
um from a three zero six zero two one
zero six two three four dollars
then you have Cloud software engineer as
a role
um uh wherein the programmers and
related computer scientists develop
softwares that operates in the cloud and
often as software as a service or
infrastructure as a service systems
right and Guys these these individuals
are responsible for upgrading repairing
and maintaining the softwares that
develop and the uh that they develop and
the database it Powers okay so that's it
and the salary again the average is uh
one one seven uh
two five zero dollars right so that's
there then you have Cloud automation
engineer now when I talk about Cloud
automation engineer so as uh stated by
Stuart that uh you should be good in the
devops part of the things right and uh
so you have uh like in if you want to go
with Azure devops then you have a
certification as is it 400 Azure devops
Associates similarly in AWS also you can
go with Azure uh AWS devops
professionals okay
um so again if you are into that so you
can expect an average salary of uh uh a
dollar one two two eight two six right
uh then again uh another role that you
can have is cloud engineer which are
responsible for managerial aspects of a
company's Cloud strategies okay and
Engineers often work alongside
Architects to ensure a company's uh
Cloud strategies are implemented okay
and here also
the average salary you can expect is one
leg thirty thousand uh 86 dollars okay
then you can also work as a cloud
consultant so guys there are so many
role uh which you can be into uh if you
are good in cloud computing or if you
want to get into Cloud right so uh these
Cloud Consultants have broad knowledge
of cloud Technologies and provide
guidance to companies looking for
cloud-based tools okay
um
the assess a company's needs and suggest
softwares and devices to best meet that
company's Technical and budgetary
requirements okay so that's there and
again here uh the average salary that
you can expect is one lakh Thirty One
Thousand six seventy eight dollars okay
um so that's what you can expect then uh
you can also become a cloud data
scientist
um and data scientists as you know they
analyze tremendous amounts of data
already there and let me tell you guys
so there are so many tools that you must
be using in your on-premises for data
analysis and for data mining and let me
tell you in in in Cloud uh like with
these big uh public Cloud providers like
AWS and ashore they have so many good
Services uh which you can use
um for
um analyzing the data uh that can be
generated by your iot applications or by
any other device so there are so many
things uh there is so much of data
real-time data and to process that there
are so many
um
things that are already in the cloud so
many services are there to process your
data so if you become a cloud data
scientist uh you learn on those things
and uh you can you'll be good in that
right so yeah so that's there then
finally uh one more uh and a big one uh
that is the cloud architect so if you
become a cloud architect
um you are going to design the framework
and you're going to tell the
organizations the uh best services so if
if there are multiple services available
for for for doing a particular job then
which is the best service to go for uh
based on the company's budgets plus uh
based on the best possible solution that
you can give them okay so all these
roles are there uh if are the career
opportunities if you get into Cloud
right
um so yeah so that is there okay thank
you
all right I think that's good
if you stop sharing your screen I will
share yeah I'll just stop sharing thank
you yeah
perfect
um
and my apologies to our LinkedIn
audience I started the LinkedIn live
stream late
about
uh cloud with us and
you need
Cloud practitioner across the different
platforms
hold on I'm having a little Network
problem
we're having terrible rainstorms out
here in California
which is where I'm based
and it's uh interfering I think with our
networking
um so as I mentioned we we talk about
um
the skills that you need able to select
the correct cloud provider for your
particular
needs and applications uh how to migrate
applications to the cloud from other
platforms
doing performance testing and workload
management
so that you know you have adequate
resources
security through identity access
management
setting up Auto scaling
for environments where if you have a
seasonal or daily variations in terms of
uh demands on or resource
you have the ability to Auto scale that
for seamless operation things like
Disaster Recovery strategies
database management so all of these
different skills come together to give
you the capability to become a cloud
practitioner so at this point we'd like
to ask that first question
that first question for our audience is
what has stopped you up to this point
from
becoming a
cloud computing expert because you
haven't found a program that has a full
curriculum with all these skills in it
is it because
you feel that a program wouldn't give
you the Practical experience that be
able to demonstrate to employers
is it difficulty with the kinds of
online learning
that you've seen uh or is it a time
constraint in terms of your personal
schedule so
we'll give this
about
15 more seconds and we'll close the poll
please do get your answers in
all right and I see that the numbers
aren't changing so I will pull here
so the
the biggest issue people have had is not
feeling that they get practical exposure
experience that they'd be able to show
off to an employer and say yes I I have
done work in cloud computing this is
what I've done and this is how I've done
it
um and then the other objections about
comprehensive curriculum and work
schedule
learning modes we'll talk about those as
well so
let me
address those here
so we're talking about the
postgraduate program in cloud computing
from caltex Center for technology
instrument education
uh this is a completely online program
you can access it from anywhere in the
world
and on your desktop or on your mobile
device
some of the material of course is going
to be uh
easier to do on a desktop or laptop
because you'll need the screen space but
you can actually watch a lot of the uh
in between content of the pre-recorded
videos that go between the actual live
classes watch those on your your mobile
device anywhere you are all this is
available 24 7 so
other than the live virtual classes
which are held on a particular schedule
um
you have the flexibility to do the work
uh anytime that fits your own personal
schedule
program is uh 11 months in duration
it requires the time commitment of about
10 to 15 hours a week
um and you need to know that going in so
that you make that commitment to make
that time but you don't have to travel
to a particular location and sit in a
conference room for weeks on end you
know that kind of intensive boot camp
environment what we've done here is
designed a way to have that kind of
intensive learning but without the
travel and the time commitment
so yet
online classes weekly with your
instructor live with your peers in your
in your learning cohort
um you get to
interact with the instructor ask your
questions
see them go through the exercises live
interact with your classmates
and that
is eight eight hours of live instruction
a week usually in a two four hour blocks
on the weekend
and
then do your
lab work your projects online in the
same learning environment with um
sandboxed
environment so that you don't have to
have a separate system or
individual separate software that to do
that work with all available to you in
the same platform
it's a comprehensive curriculum we'll
describe that
and it allows you to
cover all of the skills that we talked
about
in that 11 months
the end of it you receive a
certificate from California Institute of
Technology Caltech often from the center
of technology and management education
and the
certificate again it's actually the
cloud computing postgraduate certificate
is that here
you have over 40 Projects that you can
do
done by the end of this
program and you'll have those in your
own portfolio to show off
two potential employers or to your
current employer and say this is the
work I've done this is my capability in
cloud computing
um that includes a Capstone project
which ties together all of those skills
into one industry-based solution to a
problem and
that's
really powerful tool for showing off
your actual hands-on experience with
technology
Caltech also offers a
CEUs continuing education units which
may be useful to you if you're in a
environment where you need to prove to
an employer or to a regulatory body that
you are keeping your skills up to date
put CE user for
and um that's extremely helpful but you
also get membership in the Caltech ctme
Circle which is
uh
essentially a Alumni Association for
people who have taken courses from
Caltech ctme it allows you to do
industry networking with uh with folks
that's very useful for your career
you will be recognized that an online
convocation
she'll be able to invite friends and
family to see your
name being read out
recognizing your achievement and
finally we offer for our Learners in
India job assist which is a program
we'll talk more about
that helps you with your job search
and it extends for six months after you
earn your certificate so
all of these things are part of the
program
I'll talk a little bit about Caltech why
Caltech is such a valuable thing
um you may or may not be familiar with
the television program The Big Bang
Theory which is a
situation comedy um
about researchers at Caltech
um and they picked Caltech because when
they wanted to to illustrate
a situation with the best and brightest
scientists and engineers in the world
um
Caltech rates at the very top it's
consistently in the top five uh
universities worldwide it focuses on uh
theoretical and applied research
created a number of Nobel Prize winners
a number of other Nobel Prize winners
have gone to Caltech to conduct their
research it's the home of
the jet propulsion laboratory of NASA so
you
designs and builds the satellites and
deep space exploration craft that NASA
launches for scientific endeavors
um
the Fantastic Institution
and their ctme takes that
academic
capability and prowess and turns it into
technical learning for people in
Industry so having that on your CV is a
prestigious accomplishment and people
will recognize that in Caltech
very proud of our association there
for this program
you have to have
some pretty basic
eligibility requirements main one being
a bachelor's degree with at least 50
percent marks
does not have to be in a Technology
field
um but it does have to be from an
accredited institution a bachelor's
degree
that with an average of at least 50
percent
you can come in from a non-programming
background if you do not have
programming skills currently or
programming experience
part of this program will help you
develop the basic level
that you will need to succeed in the
program
don't have to have work experience it is
always helpful we always say that it's
very useful to have experience in the
workplace know how organizations work
you know how your role in an
organization fits in
however this program does not require
you to have that so you can come
straight out of University or college
and
come
enter this program to become a cloud
computing professional
so that's the eligibility and this point
I would ask the second question
the second question here
and just to get a feel for who's in the
audience how many experience do you
currently have
are you currently in school
um are you new in the workforce
okay and uh numbers aren't changing so
I'll end the poll here
and our audience today is excused
towards the the more seasoned
professionals
with almost half having more than five
years
um we still have about 20 of folks who
are still in school
so this is a great program that
addresses all that range of experience
if you're still in school in order to be
able to roll in the program you do have
to be in a position where by the time
you finish this program you've gotten
your degree so
if you're in your for example last
semester of University
you could enroll provided you're going
to complete your degree by the time you
complete this program so how does the
program prepare you in this point first
your time of it I would ask you
if you're able to to share
a learning environment with us
yes sure yeah
so may I just share my screen yeah I
will stop sharing mine thank you be able
to share yours yeah
and just start sharing
foreign
yeah I will just get in here
no worries we get the latest news from
Microsoft and India
okay yeah
okay let's let's get this one yeah okay
fine uh so guys see uh postgraduate
program in cloud computing
um okay so this consists of like the
prerequisites already stated by uh
through it here to you right
um so when you'll enroll into this
course uh you'll have an orientation
session from Caltech professors okay and
then after that you will begin with your
courses so basically
um you will have a course on AWS
Solutions architect associate first
course okay so there will be a bucket
like bucket of compulsory uh courses and
the electives okay so in the compulsory
courses you will have
um AWS Solutions architect associate
then Microsoft Azure architect uh
that is first you will go through
Microsoft Azure administrator is at 104
now that is the one and then you will go
with designing Microsoft Azure
infrastructure Solutions is at 305 and
then you will go through uh Cloud
Capstone project okay uh so once you
finish all of these uh you will be
eligible for PG program certificate from
Caltech University okay and after the
end of every course uh you will also get
a certificate for each course that you
will complete okay so let's say if I'll
go with AWS Solutions architect
associate okay so I'll tell you uh
what you will find there in every course
so guys you will have these things that
is uh you will have self learning videos
that are already the pre-recorded videos
uh from some a trainer that you'll find
in the self learning section okay then
the next tab is live classes so here you
will find the recordings of the live
classes okay
um so that will be available in the live
classes section
um of your life classes that you will
have with your trainer then in the
assessment section
uh you will have the assignments uh plus
apart from that
um you will find the reference materials
ebooks data files practices all these
things in the assessment section okay
apart from that I mean in assessment
section you'll find the assignments and
then you will find the reference
materials are all out here then in the
practice lab uh you will find the
um lab environment which you can launch
and let's say if you're going for a awf
course so you don't need to have your
personal account if you have it it's
good but even if you don't have it
simply learn provides you with the lab
environment so you can just log in from
the sandbox environment so you can just
log in from here and you can just log
into AWS portal and you can start doing
your Labs from here okay and once you uh
are done with this that is you have
completed your self learning classes
either 85 percent of the self learning
videos or eighty percent of the live
learning classes if you finish uh plus
if you will complete the assessment part
then uh so in assessment you will see
the assignment plus plus the projects so
if you complete one of the projects out
of here and if you have completed 80
percent of the live learning classes or
85 percent of the self learning videos
then you will be eligible to unlock your
certificate then okay so this is the
certificate so see here waiting uh what
I told you okay so uh
here uh this will be the certificate for
just one course that is if you are doing
AWS you will get a certificate from
Simply learn for AWS Solutions architect
associate similarly
um you can go and uh you can do the
other one uh that is Microsoft Azure uh
admin and then architect and there are
similar things out there also okay you
will have to uh perform those steps and
once you do that then you will be
eligible for the certificate part of it
okay so when you complete any course
here you will get the certificate
completion certificate of that
particular course and once you complete
all of these courses okay so including
your Capstone project so once you do
that then you will get the PG program
certificate from Caltech University okay
Caltech plus simply learning okay so uh
this is how you go about it even in the
uh Capstone project also you will find
the self learning video plus the live
class and
um so so the instructor will guide you
in through the class and you will be
doing the project and that's how it goes
and yeah
um like I could see in one of the polls
that was taken by Stewart that
um the reason why you're not going or
the reason for not uh learning the cloud
courses is the lack of Hands-On
activities so let me tell you uh guys
because I work as
um uh like
uh as a trainer and simply learn from
quite some time and let me tell you we
in simply learn are more into Hands-On
activities because basically when you
talk about Cloud whether it is azure or
AWS it is more off towards the Hands-On
um so you will find 70 to 80 of Hands-On
activities at least in my classes what I
take in simply learn okay so that is how
it is even with the projects and the
Capstone project that you'll find are
you will not find I don't think you will
find that there is less of the Hands-On
activity uh because there there is going
to be a lot of Hands-On activity and not
just Hands-On activity so the pattern of
uh training or teaching is that we
concentrate more on giving uh real life
examples so that you can relate to your
actual learning and to your actual work
environment and you can implement it out
there so we train you not just for
certification but also so so that you
that should be helpful in your real time
environment in your organization uh
where it matters okay uh so these are
the courses okay the compulsory courses
plus apart from this there are electives
also of course you can go for the
electives as well
um so
um there will be a master class and then
uh you will see elective two elective
three so you will uh you can go through
Microsoft uh Azure developer associate
then um AWS developer associate AWS
sysops associate AWS database migration
Google Cloud platform architect right
and when you go into all these so you
can see this is uh like Google Cloud
platform AWS database migration these
are uh self learning that means there
will be only self-learning videos you
will find in that but in AWS associate
developer associate
um Microsoft Azure developer associate
you will find a live classes
self-learning videos as well and all
those steps inside this also you will
find the scene yeah so this is uh the uh
view or the walkthrough of the LMS that
I wanted to give you I hope it is clear
to everybody and that there is no
um sh doubt if you have any queries you
can put it or you can ask
thank you thank you very much
yeah I'll stop sharing them yeah perfect
thank you
yes
there we go
so that's the learning environment as
which I'm just said
a pretty comprehensive walkthrough and
you can see everything is within the
same environment you don't have to
switch systems as you mentioned you
don't have to have personal accounts
with Azure and
AWS you get access to everything you
need within that same environment and
this is again to recap the
the
reason that the the curriculum is set up
this way it it's set up so that with
each
course you get a set of skills that will
help you succeed in the following
course or module
and the have the ability to take
electives which are no additional cost
they're based on what you're interested
in how much time you want to make for
them uh so you can take these additional
courses you can take the master classes
from the Caltech instructors
um
we recommend of course that you take as
many of these as you feel comfortable
doing because they you round out your
capabilities but with the corn core
classes only you still have that
comprehensive
set of skills
demonstrate that through the Capstone
project which we'll talk about in a
little bit more but that's something
that goes into your portfolio that you
can then show
how you did a how you solved an
industry-based problem
and how you did the work so
you're going to be exposed to a whole
variety of tools and platforms
by exposed to I mean that you will be
required to use these different projects
and demonstrate your confidence with
them so
the end of the process
when you put something like AWS Lambda
on your
resume or curriculum vitae you will
be able to say confidently yes I not
only am familiar with the tool but I've
used it and I've used it in these types
of projects so
these have become more than just
buzzwords on your resume they become
actual skills that you can demonstrate
to people
Capstone project as I mentioned is your
ability to
show that you can take a real life
business scenario
a problem that a company or an
Enterprise or an organization would face
in real world
and you can design and implement the
solution to it a drawing on all of the
skills from your
studies and program
you get to choose from several different
domains different Industries you pick
the project that interests you most and
you work uh in coordination with one of
your instructors who will Mentor you
through the the three to four weeks it
takes to complete the program of the
project you meet with them weekly that
keep you from going down dead ends or
rabbit holes
getting lost in doubts and concerns and
at the end of the process your Capstone
project is evaluated as your essentially
the final exam for the program
you take that with you out of the
program and into real life you can show
that off to employers
people who administer this program from
Caltech are Rick Hefner who has over 40
years of experience in Industry
um
coordinates with between the academic
part of Caltech University in
applied technical and management
education site of ctme
and then John wetch who specializes in
the cloud computing aspects of the
program these folks coordinate and
design the curriculum and work with us
to make sure that the content meets
their standards and is delivered
properly
um talk a little bit about learner
outcomes the one thing we talk about is
where people come from to take this
course and
people come in from you know people who
are working so we saw in the poll that
the number of folks in the audience
today who are working in Industry
currently and would like to add to their
capabilities and
people from companies like IBM and
Amazon from Abbott Laboratories
pharmaceutical from Wells Fargo Bank
um from process to all different types
of sectors
information technology and software
certainly but also banking Financial
industrial e-commerce
every industry
needs cloud computing
capability and so every industry
needs its
Associates its employees to come to
programs like this
I've also mentioned the career
assistance services
for some reason have the wrong slide
here about U.S learners but this is
available to Learners in India through
IIM
jobs and services are the same you get
access to expert webinars and career
events that simply learn puts on as a
free resource to our
students and alumni you have the ability
to choose your real world projects and
you have the job assist services
so the job assist Services through IIM
jobs are similar
we have the IIM jobs portal oops sorry
click on these things and yes it's a
select yeah the IM jobs portal gives you
the access to some exclusive job
listings
um which is valuable but I think even
more valuable are the resume review and
rewrite service
because
in today's environment your resume never
hits uh desktop or the
screen of a human being unless it passes
through an AI bot that evaluates it
first
so that filter
um
can keep you from getting to the
interview and you need to have a resume
that's formatted in a way that the AI
system can easily understand what's in
it and why it matches the job
description and so that's a form of art
but the the other aspect of that is
making sure that when the
resume passes the filter and goes to a
human being that it still looks
attractive and that the human is able to
quickly understand why you're a good fit
for the job so that is a for almost an
art form in terms of how it's done and
working with a
consultant who will help you rewrite
your resume give you a couple of rounds
of rewrites that's really a valuable
aspect to help you in your job search as
is the one-on-one interview service
and this is part of any job search
you're going to go through multiple
levels of interview both technical
interviews as well as the management
level
and soft skills interviews that talk
about your ability to work as a team
member and contribute to an organization
but you need to be able to to ask both
types of screenings and conduct yourself
well in both interviews so you'll be
able to practice that one-on-one
both in terms of how to present your
new set of cloud computing skills but
also then how to present yourself as a
valuable potential employee next level
of interviews so this is a really
valuable service again it extends for
six months after the completion of your
program so you get your certificate and
you have six months of access
it's not a job guarantee program this is
a assistance with your job search so you
need to be the person driving
the use of these Services the person who
asks for the help and then we'll give
that to you over that six month period
we talked about
expert webinars
um
conduct webinars on a regular basis
on topics like
Career Development job search
uh technology
some of these are mini classes on
technology so you might have a any class
in cloud computing with somebody like
Persia Tom for an hour to talk about a
particular aspect of technology and look
at
how to use that
um you might have a
review with someone from industry who
talks about the importance of cloud
computing skills and what the career
opportunities are coming year and then
you have general advice on time
management or other aspects of career
management
yeah so all of this is available free
webinars that you can sign up for at
your leisure and we talk about the the
Capstone and the industry-based project
so along the lines you're going to have
the ability to do uh projects with these
different types here are some examples
of
um
company like
the Netflix style online video company
or a healthcare application or a
restaurant application which
becoming more and more important in this
world
um I should mention that
um even something as uh
basic is fast food
recently there's an interview with the
head of the fast food chain Wendy's in
the United States
and they found out during the pandemic
that because they had to develop a
mobile application to let people order
from their phones before coming to pick
up through the drive-through
um they were getting a new source of
marketing data that they hadn't
anticipated
and so the understanding of how to use
all of that information the cloud and
then being able to tie through
things like if somebody has ordered in
the past they're about to
place an order to go to their local
Wendy's Outlet
what patterns of the shown and what
should you promote to them maybe induce
them to add something to their order and
all of that happens in real time and all
based on cloud computing availability
um and then e-commerce of course is the
other one so these are examples of
projects might do that you would then be
able to take and show that your solution
to a potential employer
so having said all of that and based on
what you've seen so far
just like to get a feel for the level of
interest in our audience
so is this would you like to
enroll in this program based on what
you've seen so far
let this
let this run until I start seeing the
numbers
they get the same
do you get your answers in I'm going to
close the poll in about five seconds
and here we go
so 84 of the people who responded said
they would be interested
and that's great that means that this
would be a good time to talk about how
to enroll
so the enrollment steps or joining this
program were very basic
you send an uh email to ask us at
simplylearn.net we encourage all of you
to send an email to ask us at
simplylearn.net to ask questions of our
learning Consultants but if you're ready
to enroll
you should tell them in this email that
you would like to submit an application
um the application will include your
academic qualifications because you do
have to have a bachelor's degree
so you'll have to include
proof of that and possibly transcript
um and then I'll talk about your
particular background whether you have
any experience in the field whether you
have any programming experience whether
you have any job experience again those
are not required for this program so
it'll just be a way to assess what kinds
of services you'll need if you become a
enrollee
and at the end of that process you've
met the the requirements you'll get an
admission offer from us and then you can
join the program so talk about
program itself the next batch of classes
starts in February with an orientation
coming up
in about a week and a half
and uh
that orientation suggestion is just that
first basic
get to know the program get to know the
learning management system and then the
actual live classes start on February
4th
um cost of the program for books in
India is one lock 59 000.
and that's inclusive of taxes you can
finance that with the zero percent
financing as low as 5270 in a month this
is um
your option if you make it more
affordable for you sorry
and again reach out to us at ask us at
simplylearn.net you want to do that as
soon as possible because we do have a
limited number of seats in each cohort
so
um we don't
load up
hundreds of students into one group
because the
live virtual classes only work if you
limit the number of seats so that's a
reason why you should contact us right
away
again if you're not ready to do that
soon and I'm going to ask that question
right now you should probably contact us
as well in order
tell us
um keep track with us when the next
cohorts are coming available what your
future plan is
so let's ask that question
if you're interested in the program
when would you like to start
so a quarter of the the folks who are
interested want to do this right away
it's great we want to get you involved
in that February class cohort
um people who want to do this within
three months contact us and you'll be
able to see what the next cohort after
that one is
and if you're looking further out do
contact us and
see how to keep in touch with us to
learn when future cohorts will happen
um
number of cohorts happens periodically
they usually run them every couple of
months
sometimes more frequently and again
um
please keep in touch with us and learn
about that
now
we've reached the part of our program
where we talk about your questions live
and I'm going to actually
stop sharing my screen
because you don't need to see that slide
but you can talk with the
pressure Tom about your questions let me
take a look through here
Ashish first time Ashish has a question
um yeah
this I'm currently working in the PLM
domain I.T sector has three years of
experience and would
what would you recommend in terms of a
career of cloud computing is that a good
pivot
uh he's working in which domain sorry
PLM
okay yeah so yes cloud computing if you
are having three years of experience of
course uh cloud computing is great to
start with
um because
um if you haven't experience of three
years that means you are relatively new
into your career and
um uh of course when you will get into
Cloud uh so uh it it will open a lot of
opportunities for you so the it's always
a better opportunity to uh get in as
soon as you can yeah
on Palm Coast has a similar question but
from a different background he's 16
years of experience in database
Administration infrastructure
Administration so uh yes in cloud
computing what directions
what types of uh roles would be suitable
okay so yeah is uh he's having good
experience in database domain so you can
become
um uh like you can do the certifications
in Cloud related to databases like AWS
database specialty uh and Azure database
specially uh specialty certification and
um uh of course you can implement the
same things in the cloud
uh okay and so you can go for Big Data
specialty or database specialty in in
AWS or Azure and uh that can be a big
hit for you going ahead
and
Henry asked about the price of the
program which you've already covered
um Henry if you are not in India you may
see a different price if you go to our
website to look or if you ask the
learning Consultants about it uh you
will they see a price in dollars
um
so again this is accessible to anyone
worldwide
uh the job assist service aspect of it
is only available to folks in India
um or in the U.S but we have different
programs for the US audience North
American audience
and
abhishekoja I think it's the name of
this person will we also get vouchers
for the Azure and AWS certifications
want to ask the
learning consultants for the definitive
answer but my understanding is yes you
do get the uh the vouchers for the
certification tests are included in the
price of the course
so when you complete those modules
you'll rece you'll be able to to request
vouchers
and schedule your tests with Microsoft
and with that Amazon directly
and
Nina asks about the duration of the
course it's 11 months all online
you'd meet weekly
for the
live virtual classes
I understand that over the course of 11
months there may be some weekends where
you won't be able to take a class live
you'll need to take it or review it from
a recording as you might have noted in
the walkthrough that Persia Tom did
there is a tab for past class recordings
and so if you do miss one or two classes
you'll be able to review those but you
do want to to make sure that you're
committed to take the vast majority of
your classes live right pressure
yes correct Stuart and in fact there is
one more
um thing sort of thing will I get
certificate of I sure AWS also for
course uh completion of course yes
um as I told you in the when I was
discussing India limits that uh
whichever course you complete you'll get
that certificate of uh that particular
course and at the end you will get the
complete certificate uh like from a
postgraduate certificate or Cloud
computer yeah and that's yeah that's
Sarah's question for each module you
complete you receive a
uh simply learn certificate of
completing that module and then at the
end of
the entire program you received your
Caltech ctme certificate
um
let's see
so first of time you can give some
insight into this from industry side
um with a large number of layoffs
happening in big tech companies
um how will a cloud computing Program
help us in 2023
yeah okay so I would like to say
something on this see um layoffs are no
doubt happening but um uh so when the
layouts are happening in fact you have
better opportunity if you are better
skilled okay
um let me give you the examples like uh
we we get so many corporate trainings on
uh major Cloud platforms like AWS azure
and what's the reason for that the
reason is pretty simple that because the
industries wants want their
um uh experienced employees to be
skilled on these platforms okay
so
um so they do corporate trainings right
and uh so if if they are looking for new
employees and if they find themselves
already equipped with these Technologies
so uh they are always having an edge
over the others you will always be
preferred if you are good in Cloud
because case cloud is the present and it
is also the future and it it's going to
stay because on-premisis is certainly is
not the thing uh going forward so when
it comes to layoffs so if you have
expertise in the Technologies which
matters which is required so you have
the better opportunity to be in the
industry and you can Excel more so so
for others it may be a layoff for you it
is a better opportunity I can say if you
are good in these platforms okay
um so we have an anonymous question how
many electives can you go for and the
answer is you can take one pick zero if
you want you can take one of them you
can take all of them
um there is no additional charge for the
electives and they're entirely based on
your time commitment and your level of
Interest so
um because they're electives you're not
required to take any of them but
you are given the choice of being able
to take any or all of them
that answered that question
um
in fact yeah through it there's a top
there's a question is there any topics
related to network related things in
Cloud courses you provided of course yes
there are uh if you talk about the
architect course also or admin course
also there are networking Concepts and
yes the networking concepts are covered
like let me tell you my experience only
when I take uh uh Azure admin or AWS
admin I take up the CCNA Concepts the IP
addressing Concepts and then only I
proceed because otherwise if you don't
know those
um you won't understand the networks in
Cloud right so yes we do take it up at
least I do take it up out there uh then
again uh there's another question what
level of programming language required
for cloud Solutions architect so to be
very Frank for Solutions architect you
don't need programming uh knowledge just
a basic one is also good enough or even
if you don't have that that should be
good enough
um uh because uh when you will do that
post just a little bit of Basics you can
learn about it and not more required for
Solutions architect or administrator
associate but of course if you are going
for developer associate then you should
be having the knowledge of programming
Isaac has a question what's the
difference between a cloud architect and
a devops engineer
yeah so uh Cloud architect is uh
basically see Cloud architect will be
involved in taking uh the design
decisions uh in the industries that is
for for implementing a particular
solution if there are multiple services
available uh in Cloud so which service
you should be using uh so as to get the
better solution plus uh which should
which should fit the company's budget
requirements as well and it should give
them the best solution out of the a lot
and when we talk about devops so it's
all about automation so when I talk
about devops engineer so uh he should be
good in rather creating uh an automation
pipeline uh uh CI CD pipeline that is
continuous integration continuous
deployment pipeline so that the work of
the testers or the manual jobs in the
industries can be minimized to the
extent possible so that everything uh
right from
uh submitting your codes uh to uh
deployment testing uh and release can be
automated okay so uh that is basically
the job of devops engineer if thank you
um Isaac has a question about the
financing per month uh
number 5K that is 5K Indian rupees
per month um so
want to make sure that we're not talking
about uh dollars 5278 rupees per month
um
uh or the the complete course price is
one lock 59 000.
um
uswani asks I'm not I'm from a non-it
field is this a good option for me
what would you say personal
absolutely see I'll tell you if you are
from non-it field I will not uh prefer
you to go for a developer uh course
directly but yes you can be really good
to start off with uh like a practitioner
an admin an architect yes so so it can
be uh of great great uh opportunity for
you uh because if you are from non-80
background as I told you the uh
different uh career opportunities in
Cloud so there are opportunities even if
you are from non-iit background so see
if you are from non-id background maybe
you will have to uh initially you'll
have to work a bit uh more uh harder but
then you can always get into in fact
many of my Learners are like from
mechanical background and like one of my
friends he's from mechanical he has done
is being mechanical and he's doing great
in in Amazon right now he's into Amazon
so uh yeah so that is there like uh
you will have to work a bit hard but
even if you are not good in programming
aspects so with Cloud you have many job
roles uh that don't include programming
also some of them so you can do really
uh good in that yeah that I can assure
you thank you
um
[Music]
uh if someone was a higher National
diploma in computer science can apply
for the program all the time one of the
requirements of this program is you do
have to have a bachelor's degree from an
accredited Institution
so you'll you'll have to make sure that
you have that qualification
uh if you have any question about
whether your National diploma is
equivalent
leaves contact
um ask us at simplylearn.net and funding
consultant I'll look into that for you
um avani asks about our placement
statistics and I
again contact ask us at simplylearn.net
about that but what we can say and what
we do publish is that for
uh the programs that we offer
90 of people uh say that they have
achieved the career goal that they
expected when they enrolled
um and some of our
programs that we
see placement rates that exceed 90 but
again we're not doing job placement part
of this program we are providing a job
search assistance
so um if you want better statistics I
would advise you to contact ask us at
simplyman.net see if they have
statistics they can share with you
um
is this a Celtic course or simply learn
course
um that's a good question this is the
Caltech course delivered by simpler
meaning that Caltech as you saw
John watch and Rick Hefner uh oversee
the course
make sure that the curriculum meets
caltech's requirements
coordinate delivery of master classes
with Caltech ctme instructors
um
and simply learn administers provides
learning platform
provides a
instruction some many of the courses
um again Caltech puts its full face
essentially full faith and credit behind
its um
uh certificate and the certificate you
earn at the end of this program is
issued by Caltech ctme not not simply
so they're putting their name on it
um
I hope that answers that question for
you
uh
we have another question from
and I'm not going to try because of the
email address
um but aham
talks about having 12 years of
experience with five years in business
intelligence
um
what is the best strategy for switching
over to Cloud Solutions architect career
path
okay
yeah uh so should I answer this yes
please yeah yeah so um of course you
should go with a course on AWS architect
or a sure architect and once you go with
that
um you will learn about the different uh
technicalities or the different things
that an architect should know uh once
you're good in that then you can
practice doing it in your real-time
operations and with having such a
certification and and and then having
some years of experience into it
um in your real life uh you can you can
switch to an architect
um domain pin
um
similar question uh from pavon who has
17 years of experience in Telecom
and
how does uh what opportunities in cloud
computing would be suitable for him
uh sorry he's having 17 years of
experience in what telecon okay so what
is the scope of job in cloud computing
yeah you can get into Cloud since you
are from Telecom background
um uh you can get into the admin part or
later on into the architect part of the
cloud computing yeah so I would better
prefer uh you can get into the admin
part of the cloud side initially and
then get into the architect side of it
okay
very good
um
taking a look to see what other
questions we have
talked about the course price and
duration already
we talked about the level of computing
knowledge
uh indrani talks about having experience
in software development which opens up
opportunities for cloud software
development Cloud developer uh any of
these opportunities really
um
similar for Akash who's got a year of
experience as a full stack Java
developer
and again it's easy to Pivot into cloud
computing into development or other
aspects of cloud engineering as well
um Trudy asks if you'll always have
access to the class recordings even
after the training is over so if you
have access to the class recordings for
about six months after the end of the
program
certificate we can't
keep that access available however you
do have access to
the other resources
pre-recorded video components and that
type of thing
um
for a longer period so ask the folks
that ask us at simplylearn.net about
that policy
um
the car asked if this program covers
Google AWS and Microsoft so it doesn't
cover AWS and Microsoft Azure and there
is an elective for Google Cloud
platforms that's again based on your
uh interest in the level of commitment
um
pressure Tom here's a question what
programming language
should someone learn a part from uh
taking this cloud computing program what
are the what would be a useful
programming language to okay included
yeah
yeah so I would prefer uh you to see um
from the programming side uh you should
if you do if you're going like if you're
studying I sure so uh you should go
with.net
vb.net or esp.net right that will help
for Azure developer and Java programming
language in AWS can be a lot helpful
apart from that uh knowledge on Linux
um
uh in the operating system environment
can be a lot helpful uh when when we are
when you are specially learning uh AWS
Cloud platform
um we're getting
a bit over time so we won't have too
many more questions but I will say that
uh we have a question from aham who says
there are a number of organizations
recruiting Cloud Architects with a
minimum of six years of experience
oh man his experiences in data analytics
and planning
um how would this program help you
become outstanding uh so first time you
can you can comment but let me first say
um
at the end of this program
you wouldn't necessarily
compete against people who have six
years of experience but you would be
able to look for the more entry-level
positions am I wrong about that
uh so no of course uh see he's having
six years of experience correct uh uh
he's he's saying that the the job
descriptions require six years of
experience
uh six years of experience as interest
as what as architect
yes okay so see um now I would like to
say here if the job requirement is that
it needs six years of experience so it
needs six years of experience
um there is uh there is no alternative
to that but yes of course if his profile
contains that uh he is having a
certification on AWS or Azure uh that is
architect certification in AWS or assure
so he may be considered a foreign for an
entry level position yeah may not be uh
the position uh that requires six years
of experience but in an entry level
position he can be considered and then
later on uh he can he can be promoted to
the higher positions
that makes sense
and
take this last question because it's a
three-part question and it'll be a good
way to close out the
the session um
surov has five years of experience
on Portals data in the education sector
in database management using Excel so he
asks first why should he join the course
uh secondly what would his transition
and career transition be like in terms
of you know from starting the course to
starting a new job in cloud computing
and
um
are there any other technologies that
he'd have to learn or will this course
give him a basically
a full grounding to get into cloud
computing
okay
so why should he join this course he um
I would say that if sort of yeah sort of
is his name correct so saurabh if you
are having a good experience into Cloud
already if you are already aware about
AWS and assure if you're good in that in
all these courses of course you don't
need to join this course then but if
you're not good uh but if you're good in
the database and the other Concepts in
your on-premises environment so you
should if you have to upgrade yourself
which is the need of the app because
going ahead uh even even in the present
also that is what is uh the uh need of
the it Industries okay so you should
upgrade yourself you should be good in
these set Technologies which you are in
your on-premises in Cloud as well right
and when you talk about being good in
cloud in the said Technologies like
database and stuff so
let me tell you uh the market leaders
are AWS is azure and so any company who
wishes to or who are into Cloud they are
into AWS Azure uh things yeah so you
should be good in that if you have to be
competitive in the market if you have to
be in IIT industry you have to be
competitive and if you have to be
competitive you have to be good in cloud
computing uh to go ahead uh smoothly in
your career yeah that's what I would say
correct yeah and and the best uh yeah
and uh if you can get it from the best
platform that will add uh to your resume
thank you
okay and so with that I think we I have
to apologize to everybody whose
questions we couldn't get to and we had
quite a lot and we've done a little over
time but I'm going to
um
finish the presentation
with
this last question
and this question is if you are
planning to enroll
do you need assistance you want to reach
out to
ask us at simplylearn.net
leave that here
and while you're doing that I will open
the chat and put in
a couple of items
first we have
uh
the updated LinkedIn link for
pressure Tom
it should work
thank you
and also
I'm putting in the ask us at
simplylearn.net link
into the chat
so you have that email address at your
fingertips
I'll end the poll
so again if you are interested in
joining the program please contact us at
ask us to definitely simplylearn.net
um looks like about
half of You Are
have some additional questions that you
want to get results so contact us there
if you're ready to do this but you don't
need assistance you should be able to
just go ahead contact us there and get
the application process started so
with that I want to thank
Dr Pursuit on assadami for being here
with us for sharing his
time and knowledge
and
I'm very grateful to you for that
always there for you through it thank
you thanks for giving the opportunity
yeah
and uh to everyone here in the audience
today I thank you for being here and
being patient with us I hope you found
this helpful to you we've talked about
opportunities in cloud computing and we
hope to see that this program will be
valuable to you to help you get started
in that field so contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net if you feel that way and
we hope to welcome you into the Caltech
Learning Community thank you so much and
that concludes our webinar
thank you Stuart thank you everyone